Probably the easiest case would be when the two countries are exactly equal, so
if this dot equals other country then I can immediately return zero, otherwise
if this dot area is less than other country dot area I want to return a
negative number, I will just go with minus one otherwise if this dot area is
less than, I mean greater than OtherCountry.area, I want to return a positive
number. I think one'll do. Otherwise their areas must be exactly equal, in
which case, I'll use the string compareTo method on the name, and return the
result of that. Once I fix my syntax errors, I want to check that this actually
works the way I'd expect. So I'm going to get out my code pad. And make some
new countries. El Salvador should come before Belize. So If I compare El
Salvador to Belize, I should get a negative number. So far, so good. Certainly
the opposite direction should be positive. And Belize compared to Belize should
give me a zero. And just to make sure that I'm breaking ties, let's compare
Belize to a made up country, with the exact same area. Alright, negative 11
sounds good to me. So long as compareTo doesn't return zero, with two countries
that are clearly different countries. Now, to make sure the work wasn't all for
nothing, I want to show you that now we can sort all of the Central American
countries. Using the Arrays.sort method now if I run this, now I've tempered
with the two string method a little bit just to make this easier to see, I get
the countries in order by their areas, sorting is actually an interesting task,
when many people have studied for years but we just managed to do it in one
line of code array for interfaces.